I'm gonna watch your show that sounds
really fun I'm gonna watch your show cuz
I'm insecure about how I look and sound
hey me too
I got into this because I hate myself
well you when I like people are yelling
at me all the time yeah that's what I do
I like I think people just constantly
yelling at me
do you like could you go home and think
of that show wasn't any good
and then look in the mirror and say it's
your fault it's your fault do you ever
do that all the time yeah and you're one
of the people who really inspired me to
try this Sunday will go wrong on the
show and my wife will hear me get up
this is no joke this is sad and it be
something that bugged me that didn't
quite go the way I wanted to on the show
and she'll hear me get up at like 4:00
in the morning I'll go in I'm like half
asleep but I'm like and I'm she hears me
urinating and she hears me go really
it's so sad the day we had Will Ferrell
the day we had Farallon I was leaving
for work and this is true and I haven't
talked about this I left for work and my
wife was like you must be so excited
wills coming on you psyched for this one
and I burst into tears and said to my
wife I don't know how long I can keep
doing this to myself where ladies and
gentlemen thanks again fun fun exercise
you've had a hard day at work you come
home you turn on the TV and you watch
two people who admitting that they're
having nervous breakdowns there's two
people on TV and you're not having
another breakdown you're fine right I
don't give a [ __ ] about any of this yeah
here he is the healthiest one he's the
healthiest one of all it's just a talk
show
masterpiece whatever I often actually
won oh my god I wonder if you would be
proud of me for my show and that gives
me a nervous breakdown like I wonder
would Conan like this and then I have
panic attacks
my god that's terrible I'm very proud of
you you're doing a really good job it's
all good it's all mine
yeah no I know I just feel like you're
fishing yeah and you're falling for it
yeah come on you worm do another show
yeah you're a good show what are you his
talk show dominatrix I love that all
right we got out we got to end this
thing this is madness yeah I'll cut out
the Dafoe thing
oh just ruin that I mentioned it no
everyone watching is like what was the
Dafoe thing how bad could it have been
it was really bad it was bad guys see it
put those four it on loan all right here
we go the Christian show returns Tuesday
May 8th at 11:00 on truTV he's a good
man
[Applause]
you